Angela's weathers in New Mexico hi
Angela how are you I'm doing well how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I was calling because it's long story
short but my head my husband had
fathered three children before we got
married he has separate chops for orders
on all three of them there's three
different moms and two together it's a
combined total debt of 58 thousand
dollars and I didn't know if we should
do like your traditional debt snowball
on this or how he was going about
tackling this I didn't I don't feel like
the debt snowball would be good because
I don't want to like pay for one child
and the other two are not receiving any
money well that would be a good
sentiment thank you for that how much
other debt do you guys have um about
5,000 we have car loan and small what's
your household income about thirty five
thousand okay all right um so justjust
one of you working yeah I work full-time
I make $17 an hour what does he do um he
he's always wanted to own his own
business and so this year he decided
that he was going to try and start a
landscaping company but it's very
seasonal and there's not a whole lot of
work right now so okay but I mean it did
he did he started before before winter
yes he started it in April and he was
making about five hundred to a thousand
dollars a months from that mm-hmm okay
so it's not working out no okay and I
mean unless he has a plan to get his
income up 10x he needs to get a job
doesn't he yeah
okay yes you're nervous laughter tells
me he's sitting on his butt not doing
that um not exactly well what is exactly
is he doing well he is at home with her
we have two children together so he is
at home with them right now but him
while they're at school and stuff he's
not really doing much
he's marketing the business and bull hmm
if he's marketing his business if you're
making more than five hundred dollars
yeah okay I so as kindly as I can I need
to just say out loud that there's a guy
that owes fifty eight thousand dollars
for three children that he's not taking
care of and he's doing zero about it and
that's kind of not okay mm-hmm was that
kind I was I'm feeling a little bit more
unkind than that down inside of me after
hearing this story yeah not not directed
towards you but this guy needs to take
care of the children that he is bounded
legally and morally to take care of
including the two that he's taking care
of at home there and that means he needs
to get off his butt okay that's the and
that I won't get any meaner than that
but that's that's what I'm because I you
know and his wife has called me more
concerned about the children that that
aren't even hers in a in a moral good
way a lady of ethics a lady of honor and
standards is what you are so yeah he
needs to go make like 40 $50,000 a year
working like 60 80 hours a week and pay
this back child support off is what he
needs to do and that's what he should do
starting now ready set go and so because
I think there's two things involved I
mean not only is there the the mothers
of the children that you are that you
would have to negotiate with and get
started with this thing on but there's
also the state
that's involved in some states they'll
put you in jail if you don't are not
actively addressing this stuff yeah we
did have the police show up at our door
one time mm-hmm are you parent are you
paying something on it now is that
what's Eldin them at bay um no we're
just kind of I guess he's just flying
under the radar right now I'm not sure
exactly how but he he did get his
license revoked also this guy's really
struggling at me yeah which is leaving
you in a real pinch too I think you just
feel like there's no hope
Thanks yeah he'll never be able to pay
it off yeah there's 100% chance there's
no hope using the program he's using now
in his life mm-hmm which is behaving in
a way that causes him to lose his
license and create no income yeah so
he's got to change behaviors and that's
your only shot here yeah I mean no I
would not debt snowball and pick one of
these children over the other but
overall we've got uncovered a
significant income problem that is
created by a significant hopelessness
and on his part which is also created by
his series of behaviors because what
you're described all through this
conversation is a guy who's struggling
to to work to do the right thing he's
struggling in a lot of areas so I'm if
if he were my friend and I were sitting
with him a cup of coffee here's what I'd
tell him I think you need to find a
really good Church in your area and find
a pastor who is kind but is also very
very tough and strong who will speak
into his life and help him form some of
the things that he's missing in his
character to be able to serve those
children you and your children and he'll
get great joy when he turns his life
around in that regard because right now
he has no joy there's no dignity in the
way he's behaving now
and it's not it's not helping him and
it's not impressive and it's probably
hard on your marriage it's probably hard
on you I mean you're the only one doing
anything in this story so um he
desperately needs to get some good men
in his life to walk with him and help
him get on a better track than he's on
overall and then the net result of that
can be a better income and the net
result of that can be that this back
child support bill gets taken care of
but if this this is all a symptom not a
problem the problem is is the way he's
running his life right now
and so there's spiritual elements and
character elements missing and that's
what I would tell him if he was my best
buddy or a guy I knew know well enough
to tell him that I would grab him around
the neck and say we're gonna walk
together buddy and I'm gonna feet I'm
gonna be patting you on the back and
lifting you up and kicking your butt so
just get ready for all of it